[Musique]
chinois qui vivent à Montréal se
considère comme les héritiers des
manifestants de la place tian'anmène en
juin 1989 il réclamait plus de liberté
avant d'être massacré par milliers
Fred raconte que des licol primaire en
Chine ici à douter de l'histoire qu'on y
enseignait parce que ses parents qui ont
participé aux protestations de 1989 lui
racontait une autre histoire celle de
l'espoir de millions de jeunes écrasés
par l'armée c'est pour lutter contre cet
oubli que Fred et un groupe de
dissidents organise des manifestations
le 3 juin à Toronto et à Montréal
tout comme Fred a participé aux enquêtes
sur de présumés postes de police
clandestin que la Chine aurait mis sur
pied dans plusieurs villes canadiennes
l'étudiant infiltrait le service à la
famille chinoise du Grand Montréal dans
le Chinatown afin d'établir des liens
entre certains des responsables du
service et le Parti communiste chinois
ils vont attraper s'ils veulent vraiment
tout ce qui explique ainsi pourquoi il
masque plus ou moins son identité il
juge important de dénoncer publiquement
les abus du régime chinois de plus en
plus sévères selon lui
en novembre dernier devastes
manifestations dans plusieurs grandes
villes chinoises ont forcé Pékin à
abandonner sa politique de zéro covid
c'était la première fois depuis juin
1989 que les Chinois exprimaient leur
ras-le-bol avec autant de force la
contestation a été violemment réprimée
des milliers de manifestants sont
toujours en prison sans avoir été
accusés Fred et son petit groupe de
dissidents réclament leur libération
nous avions rencontré Peter il y a 4 ans
à Montréal ville qui l'a choisi parce
qu'il adore Léonard Cohen après s'être
exprimée en faveur de la démocratie à
Hong Kong il a reçu des menaces ce qu'il
l'avait rendu très suspicieux
quatre ans plus tard Peter dit lui-même
qu'il est moins paranoïaque pas parce
qu'il a changé d'opinion sur les Chinois
qui côtoient Montréal mais parce qu'il
ne les fréquente presque plus par choix
chinoise Peter s'est rapproché de
morialet de divers horizons parce que
pour comprendre la culture québécoise
pour engager avec les communautés ici il
est important que
je comprenais cette langue les deux
dissidents apprennent le français pour
bien s'intégrer ils espèrent que le
Canada va prendre les moyens pour
empêcher Pékin d'intimider tous les
citoyens canadiens d'où ils viennent